[Música]
nunca gracias
estoy nerviosa porque es mucho más
difícil creanme estar parada en este
escenario hablándoles a todos ustedes
que bailar un ballet completo de dos
horas
así que si me muevo mucho o si no me
sale lo que tengo para decir bailo
bueno soy maría reig y soy bailarina y
creo que
la mayoría de ustedes conoce mí porque
me ha visto bailar
ha visto alguna nota me ha visto en la
tele o
el diario y fila en el premio etcétera
etcétera
comencé a y comencé a bailar
o hacer ballet a los 6 años en realidad
no tengo el recuerdo de haberle pedido a
mis padres para bailar o que haya tenido
una infancia con mucho movimiento en mi
casa como conozco muchísimas historias
de colegas que realmente bailaban cuando
eran chiquitas y
y le pidieron a sus padres para hacer
ballet o para hacer danzas yo no tengo
ese recuerdo yo lo que recuerdo es que a
mi madre le encantaba y creo que de
repente plasmo un poco su sueño en mí y
como necesitaban ponerme a hacer algo
extracurricular
después de que salía del colegio
eligieron ballet así que me tocó y me di
de frente
con lo que ahora es mi pasión y ha sido
durante muchísimo tiempo cuando entré en
esa academia en la profesora de ballet
que era una ex bailarina del sodre le
decía a mi madre que yo tenía pila de
condiciones y que me tenía que presentar
en la escuela nacional de danza y cuando
mi madre me lo planteo a los 6 a los 6
años
yo le decía no ni loca me encanta lo que
estoy haciendo y tengo mis amigas acá y
no quiero moverme así que estuve otros
años más en esa academia y al segundo
año la profesora otra vez volvió a
insistirle a mamá y yo creo que ya
porque me canso le dije que sí
bueno presentarme en la escuela y a ver
qué pasa y a los siete años ocho años en
realidad entré en la escuela nacional de
danza
y allí transcurre allí me quedé durante
ocho años y en determinado momento
llegaron unos profesores de eeuu a dar
clases
en la escuela y me ofrecieron una beca
yo en ese momento tenía 14 años y fue
una decisión sumamente grande sobre todo
para mis padres el dejarme ir y el
empezar a asimilar que yo me iba tan
chica dejé de estudiar en ese momento
dejé el colegio y me puse a estudiar
inglés porque por supuesto no sabía nada
de inglés yo siempre elegía aprender
francés que no sé si ni siquiera si
ahora se da francés en el colegio pero
no sabía nada de inglés entonces me
tuvieron que poner en un curso de esos
súper hiper intensivos
en el cual no aprendí nada después me di
cuenta y un mes antes de irme para eeuu
lloraba todas las noches yo soy muy
llorona yo por todo así que capaz que
terminó llorando él también
lloraba todas las noches entonces todas
las noches era una especie de terapia en
mi casa que te pasa por qué lloras y yo
decía voy a extrañar mucho y todas las
noches era lo mismo hasta que mi padre
dijo basta no vas
porque para ir y para enfermarte me
parece que él
esto no va a sacar nada bueno así que no
va así de un día para el otro
suspendí esa beca seguía estudiando
me acuerdo que ese año estaba en tercero
de liceos libre después de cuarto libre
quinto libre
entre el ballet del sodre que en ese
momento ya tenía 15 ahí era un ballet
muy diferente una compañía muy diferente
en la que conocen todos ustedes ahora el
ballet estaba en un momento de mucha
decadencia era muy triste no llegaban
maestros no los directores cambiaban
todos los años o cada seis meses
y creo que vivir toda esa etapa triste
del ballet del sodre en esos años me
hizo despertar unas ganas de conocer a
otros lugares y ver otros lugares y
tener la experiencia entonces empecé
cómo hablar con mis padres otra vez y
ver la posibilidad de
volver a tener la oportunidad de ser
becada y de irme nos pusimos en contacto
con esta universidad a la que yo
supuestamente tendría que haber ido años
atrás
y me entregaron me dieron la beca otra
vez y me fui para eeuu a los 17 ayer
me refiero a eeuu a los 17 estuve un año
y medio en carolina del norte en una
universidad de artes que hay muy famosa
allá y pero siempre extrañando mucho o
sea yo siempre tuve como una pierna en
uruguay y una pierna en eeuu entonces
siempre estaba como en un medio
mi familia siempre fue muy muy unida
entonces me costó muchísimo más ese
desprendimiento digamos
y unos meses antes de que se me acabara
la beca y ya tenía planeada mi vuelta a
montevideo veía que todos mis compañeros
empezaban a audicionar para diferentes
compañías de ballet y a buscar trabajo
entonces yo dije bueno yo antes de
volver a uruguay
voy a audicionar para alguna compañía
pero voy a audicionar para una compañía
grande porque en mi cabeza
jamás iba a entrar a ningún lado y en mi
cabeza yo iba a volver a montevideo iba
a seguir estudiando derecho que era lo
que me gustaba volver a estar con mi
familia con mis amigos etcétera etcétera
entonces dije voy a audicionar para el
american ballet y el american ballet es
como si yo les dijera el barça del
ballet nada ella tenía
la vara bien alta entonces audiciones
para el american ballet y me tomaron y
ahí se me arruinó todo el plan
no vuelvo más
y en realidad fue una de las cosas
increíbles que me pasó en la carrera
porque sin ninguna expectativa terminé
conociendo gente increíble bailando con
bailarines de primer nivel y es
conociendo teatros impresionantes
trabajando con coreógrafos así que nunca
me imaginé pero seguía con ese problema
de estar de un lado y del otro otra vez
volví a estar como en el medio
igualmente siempre tuve como muchísimo
apoyo familiar que si no lo hubiera
tenido creo que una carrera de estas
como pasa hasta en los deportes de alto
rendimiento es imposible seguir adelante
y creo que en cualquier profesión si uno
no tiene el apoyo y la tenacidad y esa
pasión
difícil se hace muy difícil seguir
adelante y bueno
hice muchísimos amigos allá tengo una
anécdota que es muy linda que yo recién
había llegado a nueva york y lloraba en
el baño porque extrañaba a mi familia y
una amiga ahora muy íntima amiga me ve y
me dice maría qué te pasa que cuál es el
problema del yo extraño muchísimo a tu
familia y ya me agarra así el brazo y me
dice no te preocupes que ahora nosotros
somos tu familia
trae y dije bueno es cierto no yo ahora
tengo que empezar a vivir mi vida acá
porque va a ser imposible estar de los
dos lados pero estuve los dos lados
durante 15 años 15 años prácticamente
fue mi estadía en eeuu y en cierto
momento
mi madre ya había fallecido y mi hermana
estaba embarazada mi papá se ponía más
veterano y empecé a cuestionarme un
montón de cosas mi vida personal tampoco
era tan buena tuve muchos novios salí
con mucha gente todos se iban a ser mis
futuros maridos y los futuros padres de
mis hijos y nada funcionó entonces
empecé a cuestionarme mucho el hecho de
tener una carrera muy linda afuera y
estar en este lugar impresionante pero
qué pasa con mi vida personal también y
tenía muchas ganas de acomodar todo eso
y había conocido durante el transcurso
de mis años en nueva york a julio bocca
con la boca en ese momento ya había
dejado de bailar y estaba viviendo acá
en uruguay y empezaba a dirigir el
ballet nacional y tenía en su cabeza un
proyecto increíble para desarrollar acá
y me empezó a tentar la idea de volverme
y yo soy muy así tengo como esa primera
corazonada de hacer algo
o sea como que dentro mío ya tomé la
decisión pero necesito compartirla con
todo el mundo entonces a todo el mundo
le preguntó y hablaba con mi hermana y
hablaba con mi padre y hablaba con
amigos pero yo ya adentro yo sabía que
me volvía en realidad este y tome la
decisión y me volví hace seis años
va a ser 7 va a hacer siete años que
volví y ha sido una de las mejores
decisiones que he tomado porque gracias
a eso
he estado cerca de mi familia volví a
reconectar con amigos conocí a mi novio
ahora y hace seis años que estamos junto
a mi vida personal
esta bárbara ahora no sé dónde está por
ahí este y bueno y empecé a formar parte
de este proyecto que tenía julio para
transformar el ballet nacional en ese
momento también necesitaba una primera
bailarina así que me volví para acá
sabiendo qué
mi vida profesional iba a ser muy buena
pero nunca me imaginé tener el éxito que
siento y que tengo ahora yo estoy
sumamente agradecida de que se me
reconozca por la calle
siendo bailarina que en la mayoría de
los casos pasa porque sos jugador de
fútbol no porque hagas ballet entonces
de eso me siento sumamente feliz pero
con eso vienen un montón de
de responsabilidades
un montón de presiones
que llegan naturalmente y todas las
demás que me pongo yo porque soy
perfeccionista y
y un poco histérica y obsesiva
y eso es un poco lo que lo que les venía
a comentar hoy también de que ustedes de
repente me ven en una nota en la
televisión no me ven en el escenario y
es como esa perfección y esa belleza y
todo rosado y es un mundo maravilloso
pero todo lo que hay detrás que es un
poco el título de la charla
es duro y es difícil
no deja de ser bonito pero hay horas de
preparación hay horas de cabeza y horas
de sacrificio
en todos los aspectos y estoy entrando
como en una etapa como en una etapa de
transición no estoy transición ando este
y me doy cuenta que tengo muchísimas
ganas de hacer otras cosas que me he
dedicado durante 32 años a lo mismo
y tengo ganas de hacer otras cosas no sé
qué porque me hablan de crochet quiero
hacer crochet me hablan de hacer teatro
quiero hacer teatro me hablan de dormir
quiero dormir o sea me viene bien
cualquier cosa pero siento que estoy
empezando a tomar decisiones
sobre mi carrera
siento también que mi cuerpo está
cambiando que es muy ridículo y lo que
voy a hacer y seguramente se van a reír
lo debe decir y se van a reír pero hace
dos años me empecé a despertar y me miró
así dio esto yo no lo tenía y yo sé que
es chico
pero no lo tenía antes y agua domina
cliff y no se me van
y el cuerpo ya no me responde como antes
me canso muchísimo más al bailar
qué más
no me recupero con tanta rapidez como lo
hacía antes bailaba un ballet y al otro
día estaba pronta para hacer otra
función ahora ya es no me des las
funciones seguidas porque necesito 12
días de descanso en el medio tengo un
pie que tengo tantos demás socios que ya
no hay lugar para más entonces el bajar
una escalera me cuesta es horrible no
para de kobe vemos como 90 años
por eso estoy cansada y este y bueno
nada es todo ese sacrificio y esa
dedicación que le he puesto al valer y a
la danza durante 32 años y creo que
ahora es momento de empezar a pensar en
en otras cosas
y seguramente no voy a ser tan exitosa
pero pero tengo ganas de probar
creo que resumiendo un poco ese es a
grandes rasgos mi detrás de escena y
estoy segura que todos ustedes en lo que
hagan pueden cerrar los ojos un momento
y ver realmente todo lo que les ha
pasado y
y es increíble y no sé y me parece que
lo que quiero dejar hoy es que a pesar
de todo ese sacrificio y todos esos
planes que uno tenga entonces esos
sueños que no tengan que a veces salen a
veces no salen
hay que darse como una palmaditas y
decir resiste un buen trabajo y bueno
creo que eso es lo que he intentado
hacerlo así que muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]